Brother Abu Shahis from Malaysia.
Bismillah Rahman Rahim. Alhamdulillah
Rabbil Alameen was-salatu was-salam ala
Ashraful Anbiya'i wal Mursalin wa ala
alihi wa sahbihi ajma'in.
I welcome you brothers and sisters with
Islamic greeting Assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi taala wabarakatuh.
Wa'alaikum assalam warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh. The topic of my short talk
today is DDYC.
Or rather, dakwah or destruction, your
choice.
Brothers and sisters, one of the name of
Quran is Al-Furqan, which means the
criterion.
But natural, you will find in Quran a
lot of examples and stories of early
generation, of earlier people where they
have attained success or they have
earned
loss for themselves.
My question to you is, would you like to
put yourself in a position, in a state
of loss?
I'm sure not. I would like to give you
an example of a surah, of a ayat from
Quran, rather two. In Surah Al-Baqarah,
surah number two, ayat number 159, Allah
says, "Lo,
those who have hide the proof and
guidance which we revealed
after we make it clear in in the
revelation, those are accursed by Allah
and by those who have power to accursed.
Surah Al-Baqarah, surah number two, ayat
number 159. There were earlier
generation who received Kalamullah and
they hide.
Where's the another example is Prophet
Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam who
received the revelation, the Kalamullah,
and he shared and he encouraged all of
us to share as mentioned in Surah
Al-Asr, surah number 103. Bismillah
Ar-Rahman Ar-Raheem, wal asr, innal
insana lafi khusr, illal lazina amanu wa
amilus salihati wa tawasu bil haqqi wa
tawasu bis sabr. The four criteria of
those who are going to attain success is
those who have faith, those who do
righteous deed, those who invite others
to talk the truth, and those who invite
others to patience and perseverance.
Brothers and sisters, whichever corner
of earth you might be, whichever place
on earth you might be, I encou- I urge
you to stand up, equip yourself with
good knowledge, good manners, or in
fact, the first is taqwa. Equip yourself
with taqwa, good manners, knowledge, and
stand up and do dawah.
I would like to conclude with a simple
dua and I would encourage and I would
invite all of you to join me. Bismillah
Rahman Rahim. May there be a da'ee in
every Muslim home, inshallah. Wa akhiro
da'wana al hamdu lillahi rabbil alameen.
Assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh. Wa'alaikum assalam
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.
Brother Atiq Naik from Netherlands.
A'uzubillah minash shaitanir rajeem.
Bismillah Rahman Rahim.
Assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.
Wa'alaikum assalam warahmatullahi
Dear brothers,
today my topic is mercy of Allah Subhana
Wa Ta'ala.
Before I start that, I want to share a
story about
my cousin who is actually going through
cancer.
And uh
well, he's not been praying and he's
basically given up hope of mercy when
when his relatives tell him like, you
know, the doctor has basically given him
time now. He's like, he doesn't have
much time left. So,
when my relatives are telling him like,
you know, he should pray
before his time comes,
you know, he's he's saying like, "Oh,
you know what? I've been so disobedient
all my life that what's the point of
praying right now? Like, what's the
point? Like, I'm I'm doomed. Like, I'm
doomed like I've disobeyed so much like
Allah is not going to forgive me."
And when I heard that, I was like very
touched. I was very touched and I was
like very I resonated with him.
Because I was like him. Like, I've been
very disobedient. Like, I have been I
haven't been on my prayers for a long
time. Like, I've been very disobedient.
And by the
mercy of Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala, he
guided me back to the right path. And I
was afraid all this time. I was like,
I've been so disobedient. Like, Allah
would not forgive me.
And then, I heard the Sheikh
talk about the Surah from Quran. It's
Surah Al
Zumar, chapter number 39,
verse number 53,
where Allah says, "Oh my slaves, the
ones who have transgressed against their
own souls,
do not ever despair from the mercy."
And Allah here does not only tell us why
do not despair from the mercy. He gives
us a reason why not why why never it's
haram for us to give up hope on Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala. And next line, he
says, "Because Allah forgives all your
sins.
Because he is the most
merciful and the most
forgiving."
And he said it goes on to say,
"Come come come to your repentance. Come
to true repentance. And
you know, submit to Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala before the death takes you over.
Because once the death takes you over,
there is no help." And when I came
across this verse, I was
very touched. I was very touched. And uh
I would like to relate to Hadith here
from uh
Bukhari,
where um Prophet Muhammad Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam
uh related
one of the stories of a man from Bani
Isra'il. He had killed 99 people.
He had killed 99 people, and he went to
a moth
asking him like uh he wanted to repent.
So, he
So, he went to a monk asking him, "Will
my repentance be accepted?"
And this monk told him, "Well, you know,
you have killed 99 people. Like, no
way." And so, he killed him. So, now it
became 100. So, he he kept on seeking
another monk like
uh seeking for advice on repentance. And
this this man told him like if he goes
to so-and-so village his repentance will
be accepted.
And he started his journey to this
village and on his way you know the
death took over him.
And
uh at when the death took over him the
angel of mercy and angel of
uh punishment were quarreling like what
what what should we do with him? And
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala brought the the
land where he was going to repent closer
to him and thus forgive him.
Uh
Well, that's what I can only share one
story with you. And
thank you very much. As-salamu alaykum
wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.
Wa alaykum as-salam wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh.
Brother Muhammad Imran Fazal from India.
A'udhu billahi min ash-shaytani rajim.
Bismillah ar-Rahman ar-Raheem.
As-salatu was-salam ala Rasulika wa ala
alihi wa sahbihi ajma'in. Amma ba'd.
Rabbi zidni ilma. Rabbi ishrah li sadri
wa yassir li amri wa uhluld uqdatan min
lisani yafqahu qawli.
Today I'll be talking about khutuwati
ash-shaytan.
I was thinking about this and I had a
another different story altogether but
uh
alhamdulillah
um I have something better to talk
about.
So inshallah if I have more time I'll
cover the story too.
In Surah Baqarah ayah 168 says
Ya ayyuhan nasu qulu mimma fil ardhi
halalan tayyiban
wa la tattabi'u khutuwati ash-shaytan.
Innehu
>> So what we see here is that
God is warning the mankind entire
mankind that
you can have anything on this earth
which is halal for you and pure.
However,
stay away
from following the footsteps of the
Shaitan
because he's a clearly
an enemy to you all.
So this thing, I mean it seems sounds
very familiar, right? This the message
uh was also conveyed once before in the
same surah.
So when I read read it again, I saw that
there was
the same message conveyed to Adam
Alaihis Salaam
when he uh in in Baqarah ayat 35
uh when he's warning Adam Alaihis Salaam
that
um
you can have anything
from the paradise.
However, do not
eat from the
fruit from the from that tree.
And he says
unless lest you would be among the
wrongdoers.
So when we look at the comparison here,
he's talking about the the people who
are there, the entire mankind and the
only mankind.
And when we look at the location, this
is the residence for us now. That was
the residence The paradise was the
residence for Adam and Eve then.
And when we look at the warning here,
he's warning us to stay away from the
Shaitan, but there he was warning
uh
In the context it's about food, but then
the warning is that you will be among
the wrongdoers.
From that lesson what we learned in the
previous time was that
uh Adam Alayhis Salaam was
uh actually the one who went out of his
way, but Shaitan was the one uh his uh
shown here in this ayah.
The difference was that Adam Alayhis
Salaam repented, while Shaitan did not.
Hence, repenting is something that could
save us from the wrath of Allah. And by
repenting, we can avoid from following
the footsteps of Shaitan.
Uh with this, I would like to conclude.
Wa akhiru dawana walhamdu lillahi rabbil
alameen.
La
ilaha illallah.
Muhammadun rasulullah.
Arju ridhaka ya Allah. Antar rahimu ya
Allah. Habni ataka ya Allah. Antal
karimu
minkal atawu ya Allah. Antal azimu ya
Allah. Fikal rajawu ya Allah. Antal
halimu
Rahmanus Sattaru Malikul Mulkil Ghaffaru
Wahhabul Mannanu Muta'al.
Ar-Rahmanus Sattaru Malikul Mulkil
Ghaffaru Wahhabul Mannanu Muta'al.
Allahu Allahu ya Rabbi ya Allah.
Allahu ya
Rabbi ya Allah.